[Music]
[Applause]
dane's been waiting long enough
uh his name is dane brugler he was on
the college draft podcast this week i'd
have him on every week if i could he is
an absolute stud
check him out on twitter at dpbrugler
his rankings his everything dane knows
everything about these guys like even
kids i know from high school
he knows things about them in high
school that i didn't know it's
unbelievable dane it's ross twice in one
week man good to talk with you
you too i gotta tell you that lead in uh
if this is a prospect interview i don't
know if that's
a red flag or more likely to draft you
now i can't tell
all right so dane you are young looking
but can you
at least be with me and agree with me on
80s music
sure i mean i was born in the 80s um and
you know i went to plenty of 80s parties
in college
uh so you know i i've got my phil uh
yeah i'm with you i mean i like i said i
at first i was a little
i don't know this might be a red flag
but the more you got into it i was like
all right i'm with it i'm liking this
so yeah i'm with you you know what you
know why you should like it you know why
it's not a red flag
you want people that are passionate
about things in life
and you know what scout broogler i am
even more passionate about football than
i am about 80s music
and that's type of passion i'm going to
have for your team if you draft me
i love it i love it that's sold third
round grade
all right so here's the deal all right
trey lance
played fcs football i played one
double-a football
he played one year as a red shirt
freshman
and that's it then he played one game
this fall and now he's supposedly a top
ten pick
so he's got his pro day today i guess
the first question dane is
is this like the most important pro day
ever i mean where do you put this in the
in the pro day all-time importance
rankings there's no combine
he played one year of fcs football
right obviously this uh pro day carries
a little bit extra weight
uh just with uh you know you set it up
17 starts at the college level
uh he's an unprecedented evaluation
there's no other way to say it
obviously we've seen players from the
fcs level uh go to the nfl at
quarterback find success
carson wentz uh jimmy garoppolo go back
to steve mcnair
uh but we've never seen an fcs
quarterback with you know only 20 years
old
with such meager experience uh but i
also have his talent level
uh go to the nfl like this so only 17
career starts and
none of those starts against fbs
competition a lot of times you know he
might have one game against iowa state
or something like that
not not with him and because he's only a
redshirt sophomore we don't have the
benefit of the senior bowl
or you know to see him with a better
competition that's something that really
helped carson wentz and jimmy garoppolo
when they were coming out as seniors so
it's really an unprecedented evaluation
and that's not a reason to not draft him
but it does make it a little bit more of
a challenge especially because at north
dakota state
they they have their offensive identity
they're not going to change just because
they have
maybe a higher level quarterback uh in
his 17 career starts
uh lance averaged 18.6 past attempts per
game
while the team averaged 45 rush attempts
per game so this is not a quarterback
that had to put the team on his back and
make things happen
uh he did it plenty plenty of times but
that's not how the offense is set up so
uh his pro day today is going to be well
attended by nfl teams just like his one
game was back in october
uh and they want to see him throw the
ball how the ball comes off his hand
but more importantly it's going to be
about the interviews for trey lance
where is he mentally in his development
um i thought north dakota state did a
really nice job in terms of
uh getting him ready for this moment
quincy avery his quarterback trainer who
works with a lot of nfl quarterbacks
like deshaun watson
has you know he's told me how advanced
he is for a 20 year old and that goes
back to north dakota state
and what they do during the week uh in
terms of putting more and more on his
plate
uh preparation techniques uh things like
that so on game day
he can set protections he can uh make
checks do all these things and have that
freedom so
even though he is 20 years old even
though he has meager experience
i think teams are going to be impressed
with the chance to sit down with him and
really talk to him
unfortunately this year it's just gonna
be all virtual you know in past years
they'd be taking him out for dinner uh
last night before the pro day
we're out for lunch today after the pro
day not gonna have that opportunity this
year it's all gonna be virtual so
just everything's different and that's
gonna make it really interesting for a
player like this who's
again such as an unprecedented
evaluation so
dane i know you know this how did he get
to north dakota state i mean he's 6'4
220.
i've seen him throw a beautiful deep
ball he's got a strong arm i was reading
the next gen stats he's got
four carries over 20 miles an hour like
he
he appears to be a total physical freak
show
how did he get to north dakota state in
the first place how does that happen
born and raised in a small town uh in
minnesota
about 150 miles west of minneapolis so
you know that's
that's the first thing and he was really
a running back uh
most of his life until he got to high
school and they moved him to quarterback
becomes a starter as a sophomore and it
kind of grew from there he got better
and better
but you know even as a senior he was
playing safety he had 54 tackles and
three interceptions as a senior safety
which you don't see a lot uh you know
with these top quarterbacks
usually they're quarterback only and
that's it they're going to quarterback
camp since they were 10 years old
that just wasn't the case uh with trey
lance and so as a recruit
you know a couple fbs teams did look at
him western michigan
uh they offered him right before signing
day boise state got in the mix a little
bit later
but at that point he was already set on
north dakota state and you know he goes
there
red shirts and then it has that uh
prolific red shirt freshman year where
uh he had uh what was it was uh
28 touchdowns zero interceptions uh it
was just a remarkable registered
freshman campaign
led north dakota state to the fcs
national title uh baby drew it up
textbook what you want uh but it's the
only season we have to go off of based
aside from that one game in october so
the sample size isn't great
but the talent is sure intriguing
talking with dane brugler
from the athletic at deep pbrugler
on twitter by the way dane's the only
one that knows 54 tackles for trey
lance's senior in high school nobody
else knows that 54 tackles
three interceptions i guess the last one
on lance
because i want to ask you about a couple
other guys is just is there a player
in the nfl comparison that you like and
has there ever been another
circumstance like this where a guy
really only played one year
you know we've seen guys uh stay at the
quarterback position play
one season um you know mitchell trubisky
obviously
uh you know that was well well a lot
talked about during his lead up to the
draft
but the the one quarterback where you
you can draw some comparisons as kylo
murray
when you think about the skill set now
lance is bigger
um and kyler is a little quicker
but in terms of the sample size the
number of starts
it's similar um in terms of you know on
tape you see
a lot of one read and run throws but you
see a smart guy who's able to create
um you know he has the arm talent but he
also has the mobility
so i think there's some comparisons
there uh just in terms of style
now again uh lance is bigger not quite
as quick
but uh you know in terms of uh what they
did at the college level
and uh what they could do at the next
level i think there's some similarities
so
you know but this is unprecedented
really when you again when you talk
about a player from the scs level
having such meager experience and not
having the benefit of the senior bowl
you know carson wentz he only played
or he was only a year and a half starter
at north dakota state
but him going to the senior bowl really
helped himself that went from a
yeah he could probably be a first round
pick to all of a sudden he's in the top
three mix
and the eagles are trading up for them
so not having the senior bowl not having
that combine
that's uh that's a it's a missed
opportunity unfortunately
but again that's not the reason not to
draft him it just makes a little bit
more of a challenge
when you try to figure out okay where
does he uh s
where does he stack especially in a
class like this where there's a lot of
other quarterbacks with lawrence and
zach wilson justin fields matt
uh mac jones so plenty of options at
quarterback in this class
you mentioned that i'm curious is is
lance your number three guy or do you
have fields ahead of him it seems like
everybody has lawrence one wilson too i
guess not everybody sims has wilson one
but
most people have lawrence one wilson two
is it lance or
fields three for you um i you know i i
think right now i've got fields three
lance four
but those guys are neck and neck for me
um i i do think
lawrence uh is the clear top guy uh and
then zach wilson i
you know back in the fall i kind of put
it out there that hey this guy's got a
chance to be the number two uh
quarterback
and you know that's really kind of come
to fruition i think we talked to people
around the league
they they love zach wilson they're
really intrigued with what he can do and
that skill set
and then three and four that's where
it's interesting because i think you
have
justin fields and trey lance both have a
lot to offer
uh physically talented i think it really
comes down to figuring them out
mentally where are they in their
development um you know with
justin feels what he was asked to do in
that ryan day offense compared to trey
lance what he was asked to do in north
dakota north dakota state
very very different and so three and
four to me are very close and then
you've got
uh mac jones who you know it's matt
jones is difficult because
you know you have if you list that what
you're looking for the quarterback
position you know the traits
you start with decision making and
accuracy those are one and two
and mac jones has that uh so
you know i i think you have to look at
everything else and say okay is he good
enough in these other areas
where you know he's going to be a guy
that you know could be a starter for us
and so
each team's looking at that differently
some teams that have a more established
roster are going to be more interested
in him
while some other teams that you know
need more out of their quarterback
they won't be as high on on the alabama
quarterback so a really interesting
dynamic and
uh between these quarterbacks and how
the teams are going to view them
it's kind of crazy i mean you probably
know some of this off the top of your
head
dame aren't there some like power five
schools that
haven't had a guy drafted at all in like
20 years at the quarterback position
meanwhile north dakota state's gonna
have a second
top ten guy in like six years give me a
couple of programs off the top of your
head i'm sure you know a couple
that haven't had a guy drafted or
drafted high in a long time
well ohio state was like the ohio state
had not had a first-round quarterback in
a
long long time before dwayne haskins
and obviously ohio state is cream of the
crop when you talk about recruiting
you talk about college level players uh
and they had not produced
uh you know a a high level quarterback i
mean you could go back to the 70s
um and you know they they it it's it's
interesting because
uh you know north dakota state has
really done a great job
identifying these guys and then
developing them and that goes back to
what they're asked to do or what they're
asked of their quarterbacks
in terms of during the week and their
preparation um really really impressive
so
uh yeah there's a lot of programs uh you
know even before
uh last year with tua you look at
alabama and the quarterbacks that they
produced not a high a lot of high-level
quarterbacks even during the nick saban
era
uh tua was the the first first rounder
in a while so yeah there's plenty of uh
top-level college programs that have not
produced the type of quarterbacks that
north dakota state has
here's what you got to do you got to
check out dane on twitter at
dpbrugler check out all the stuff he's
doing for the athletic you can hear him
earlier this week
talking about the guy that was a punter
basketball player only
as a junior in high school that might
get drafted at tight end
in the nfl draft on the college draft
podcast part of the ross tucker
podcast network dane you are the man i
meant what i said thank you so much
nice to have thanks ross there he is
dane brugler
love dane brugler